all right good evening i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this evening to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 100 block of
montebello
which is or i'm sorry montello which is
a residential area near the intersection
of nellis and stuart
i stress the details that i'm sharing
this evening are very preliminary but at
around 2 pm this afternoon
metro police responded to a report of a
male who'd been shot in a vehicle
directly behind me that male is a
hispanic male in his early twenties who
was transported to umc trauma where he
was pronounced deceased
what we have learned is the driver of
the vehicle the deceased male
was parked in the street in front of his
residence when an unknown hispanic male
approached him there was an altercation
of some
sort in the street and the suspect fired
multiple rounds
striking the victim the victim drove
from the scene
in about 500 yards away crashed his
vehicle into a drive or
the front yard of a house behind me
that person who lived there then called
9-1-1 and that is where the mail was
found
and transported to the hospital i urge
anybody who has information to please
reach out to crime stoppers there's
reward money available if your
information leads to the arresting
conviction
and you can remain completely anonymous
you can also reach out to homicide at
lvmpd.com
so with that i will take a couple
questions but again it's very
preliminary
in the investigation
so any gang affiliation here that you're
aware of
at this point there's no gang nexus that
we know of we've
asked our gang investigators to come out
to assist just
to make sure and we can rule that out
but at this point there's nothing that
we can
tie to any kind of gang activity what
about motive in general
drugs or did they know each other do we
know that much right now we're still in
the process of
trying to determine that there was like
i said the
victim was parked in the roadway when
the other person approached him so we're
trying to figure out what led up to the
shooting
we don't know the specifics pertaining
to motive at this point
right now we're still getting some
conflicting information we're still
trying to
piece together that information right
now we're canvassing the area looking
for surveillance video to
see if we can get some answers to that
question right
thank you guys